hello everyone
my name is cherise torres i'm the global
director of inclusion at google and i'm
excited
to partner with my colleague ruby cheng
from the gcp
k-12 education team speak with you about
the role of employee resource groups
in building a culture of inclusion and
belonging
ruby will kick off our time together
with a deep dive into the women at
google cloud group
and i'll give an overview of google's
overall approach
to employee resource groups over to you
ruby
thank you cherise hi everyone i'm ruby
chang
i serve as one of the global leads for a
woman at google cloud and i also serve
as a google cloud platform for k-12
education
lead across north america our chapter of
lemonette is a global network of about
850 women and allies that are passionate
about building a diverse and inclusive
culture
where all of us can thrive and bring our
whole selves to work
more broadly womenette is the largest
erg at google
with over 120 chapters at 52 offices
globally
our start was very grassroots back when
we were a small team
with what was then google enterprise
three women just wanted to connect with
others across their team
and even without a designated leader
they had a desire to get to know one
another
so they just got started with video
meetings which eventually became
face-to-face lunches as the team grew
and that eventually evolved to the
large-scale programming that we're at
today
it has been incredibly powerful to see
this community grow into a global
network
and looking back at our humble roots and
successful years since then
we've also seen that there are times
when we needed a lot of help
when we needed to seek out executive
sponsorship and times when we couldn't
find any
what has really helped us through all
this is staying centered on a mission
we're a global network focused on
empowering connecting
developing and retaining talent within
google cloud
this is not just important for the cloud
team but it's also aligned to google's
erg
and woman at goals we have a committed
leadership team that meets weekly and we
get together twice a year for an offside
that keeps us true and focused to our
mission we use that time
to evaluate the past few months look at
the feedback
and plan events and avenues to bring the
full community together again you'd be
correct imagine that our professional
relationships
very quickly become very personal ones
as we dedicate time to get to know one
another better
and tap into each other's strengths we
have no budget
so we rely entirely on our commitment
our creativity
tenacity and passion to get things done
we have three pillars that guide women
at google cloud and connect back to the
heart of everything that we do
and as i share these pillars and some
examples with you i also want to share
some things that we've learned along the
way
our first pillar is to raise awareness
this speaks to raising awareness around
gender diversity
as well as promoting talent to join and
develop with google cloud teams
for example we maintain a cadence of the
cloud staffing teams and check in
quarterly
we have a dialogue on how our community
can support their goals
we want to be intentional about creating
connections and host
external recruiting events as one app
needs to do so
that encourages industry talent to
consider joining our team
i mentioned earlier the idea of an
executive sponsor at one point
we just didn't have women leaders to
take this on with us
but executive leadership is crucial to
erg success
we're so lucky to have nina harding
google cloud's chief of global partner
programs and strategy
to take this on and her sponsorship and
advocacy are
key to elevating the impact of our women
and allies at the leadership level
our second pillar is building the
community it challenges us to really
consider
how do we create a culture that helps
retain women talent and is inclusive of
allies
especially now in a digital environment
this is not something that we can do
just once a year chucking off a box with
one event or being a
big idea we approach this as a series of
experiences
and it requires a lot of communication
and activation across our entire global
team
let me take you through one one decision
a way to
represent our unique culture is with a
brand or logo that represents what we
stand for
so we embarked on launching a fun lego
contest we collected submissions
held a boat and our finalist was a great
graphic of a woman
avatar with a superhero cape traveling
behind her
we loved it but we also started hearing
from our community
that perhaps this was not the most
representative icon to represent
all woman in cloud the avatar was slim
had a lighter skin tone and was
able-bodied and we took that feedback
very seriously
so we opted instead for a more inclusive
colorful
text-based logo that we have today and
it was only second by a few votes anyhow
outside of creative choices there are a
lot of logistical decisions for a
community of hundreds of members
so to scale we have to be intentional
about aligning on our communication
channels
we primarily use google groups which
functions both as our message board
as well as our email distribution and
this group is intentionally
created to be a public and not private
group so that all googlers can read and
engage
it allows us to maintain an open culture
and approach to events
and discussion we also have an
internal web page that serves as a home
base for upcoming activities
past archived events and more
there is a unique challenge when your
team grows globally and in order for
that to be effective
we really need to think global and
empower folks to activate and organize
locally
we have an incredible network of
ambassadors who help lead the women at
presence in their local home offices as
part of this effort
we're also very proud of our recently
formed regional chapters in the mia and
aipac
and functional chapters that are
organizational or team-based
like women of core infrastructure we tap
into each other's platforms
and connect as a stronger global network
of women and allies
we also want to recognize that community
is inside and outside
there needs to be a balance between the
work that we do here at google
and how we share and invite other
leaders to join us in that mission
last year we partnered with the kellogg
school of management to launch a global
speaker series
where we brought their professors who
are experts in the field
to deliver sprints of professional
development topics
we had about 200 members attend each
talk and it sparked
internal dialogue with one another in
addition to offering
external networking opportunities
our third and last pillar is empower and
develop
this is centered on providing
opportunities for professional
development and training
as well as supporting the promotion of
women to leadership positions
it is so important to create a culture
of celebration and recognition for the
growth and accomplishments of what we do
our members every day go well beyond
just our teams or our customers
we have an opportunity to share our
knowledge learn from one another
and create stronger impact when we act
together so every quarter we highlight
the awesome work happening around the
world in a newsletter
and encourage recognition across teams
into our senior leadership
this is another place where executive
sponsorship really comes in
we want to lift amplify and build trust
across google cloud
if there's one lesson we've picked up
since 2014 it's that we're always
learning
we're always growing and it never hurts
to have some fun along the way
looking ahead while we're all navigating
the remote working situation
we especially want to lean into
listening to our community
in march we took steps to re-evaluate
all of our 2020 programming
thinking should we scrap and re-plan our
events
and the thought occurred why don't we
just ask our folks what's important to
googlers now
how do we support our women and allies
during work from home
after that poll we heard that a priority
really fell into threefold one to have a
better understanding of the company
resources available to them during coven
19
so we hosted an open q a dialogue with
our partners on the people operations
team
to promote discussion and information
sharing for the unique situations that a
lot of our members are actively managing
today
second googlers want to spend more time
with cloud leaders
so we launched candid cloud an open
discussion with two regional club
leaders every month
and third googlers don't want to slow
down when it comes to internal
and external networking opportunities so
we always ask ourselves
how can we integrate this in everything
that we do
one thing we did learn that folks really
don't want right now
is another group chat it seems that a
lot of us are experiencing chat fatigue
so we're pivoting toward a digital
workplace at least for now
we've found unexpected opportunities
while the past few months have not been
easy for most of us
in some ways it's become easier to think
beyond the walls of our office
and come together as one global team now
that you know more about women at google
cloud
cherise i want to welcome you to share
more on google's broader erg strategy
thanks ruby i'll start with a brief
overview of the erg structure at google
and the role of ergs in fostering a
sense of community
within underrepresented groups i'll
close with a few case studies
of how organizations can partner with
ergs to foster a sense of belonging
both within underrepresented communities
and across the company
and just the caveat while we are excited
to share some of our learnings with you
today
we are by no means experts in this space
let's start with an overview
of ergs at google we have 16
employee resource groups with over 35
000 members
in 50 offices around the world in
addition to the employees who volunteer
their time
to serve as leaders for our employee
resource groups each of our ergs
is supported by a team of global and
regional community advisors
dedicated to supporting the ergs by
driving opportunities for connection
personal and professional development
community advisors drive this work in
three ways
first they empower erg leaders by
providing
strategic advisory support and
centralized
cross-erg functions such as budgeting
governance and quarterly lead summits to
share best practices
community advisors help erg leaders to
recognize
and apply the leadership skills that
they're gaining in their community role
and apply them to their core jobs
they also form a bridge between our ergs
which typically serve early
to mid-level career googlers and
executive councils
comprised of senior leaders from each
community serving as advocates and
sponsors for erg initiatives
as well as mentors for more junior
members of each community
second community advisors supplement the
programs created by local erg chapters
with programs designed to benefit erg
members around the globe
for example community advisors host
annual women of color summits
an erg buddy program to assist in
onboarding new employees
allyship workshops and pilot sponsorship
programs to support career progression
for underrepresented communities
finally community advisors helped to
strengthen google's business
by partnering with erg and executive
council leaders
to infuse the perspectives and needs of
underrepresented communities
into new and existing google platforms
products
and policies next i'll move into a few
examples of how ergs
help to foster community within
underrepresented groups
i'll use ola as an example hola is our
global erg
focused on the hispanic and latinx
community with the mission to progress
the inclusion
advancement and representation of
hispanic
latinx and their allies across google
olaf fosters community through a
combination of informal gatherings
such as first tuesdays where community
members gather for lunch
at designated cafes in each office on
the first tuesday of each month
they also have book clubs and spoken
word open mic
nights we combine these informal
programs
with formal programming such as the
annual ola leadership summit
providing a unique space for ola members
to build community
develop and better position each other
to lead both within
and outside the context of the hispanic
and latinx community
the annual latinas at google summit a
two-day event
created for latinas by latinas with the
intention of building community
providing networking opportunities and
developing career growth
as well as annual hispanic heritage
month celebrations
ola also holds annual service trips such
as their 2019 volunteer mission
to puerto rico to assist the community
in recovery efforts
after hurricane maria i'd like to close
with two case studies of how community
advisors
partner with erg leaders and executive
councils to foster a sense of belonging
specifically by supporting
underrepresented communities
in times of crisis my first example
relates to the asian community as many
of you may know
the asian community particularly in the
united states
experience heightened xenophobia in the
context of coven 19.
our community advisors work hand in hand
with the leads from the asian google
network
our erg dedicated to supporting the
diverse multicultural asian community
and the asian leadership group our
executive council
of senior asian google leaders to
provide a combination of resources
to support the asian community in the
midst of this crisis
first advisors partnered with the asian
leadership group
and other google senior leaders outside
of the asian community
to send messages of acknowledgement
support
and solidarity to asian googlers
next we paired community support
sessions and wellness resources
for the asian community with a digital
agn
covid19 community support hub
centralizing agm programming
resources and communications to support
asian googlers
through covid19 and related issues of
racism
and xenophobia an agn giving campaign
was set up to raise funds for six
us-based non-profits
supporting asian community relief
efforts with google matching up to ten
thousand dollars
in donations per googler finally
we affirmed along with over 100
corporations
and partner organizations the kovid 19
action agenda
penned by ascend the largest non-profit
pan asian organization
for business professionals in north
america this combination
of internal support with external
advocacy
is helping to create a culture where
asian googlers feel seen
connected and supported in the midst of
crisis
my second example relates to the black
community
over the past several years particularly
in the summer of 2020
violent and racist attacks against the
black community
are forcing the world to reckon what the
structural and systemic racism
black people have experienced over
generations
specifically in the aftermath of the
murder of george floyd
community advisors partnered with global
leads from the black googler network
an erg designed to cultivate black
leaders
empower communities and transform
technology
and the black leadership advisory group
our executive council of senior black
google leaders
to step up for the black community and
reaffirm google's commitments to
inclusion
and racial equity similar to our
approach with the asian community
we began by acknowledging the pain of
the black googler community through
messages of support
from the black leadership advisory group
senior leaders
outside of the black community as well
as organic notes of solidarity
from other ergs and executive councils
we're following with a series of
community support
allyship and anti-racism education
resources
centering first on supporting black
googlers with community building
mental and physical well-being tools
then
following with a series of company-wide
and small group sessions
to assist googlers at every stage of
their allyship journey
specifically in the context of racial
equity
our internal sessions focus on bias
privilege and immediate steps googlers
can take to show up for their colleagues
in times of crisis and at all times
we followed our internal programming
with a dedicated search for racial
equity series
on the public toxic google platform
featuring experts in the field of
anti-racism
civil and human rights most importantly
we went beyond words to concrete actions
in support of both black googlers
and black communities around the world
by publicly committing
to build sustainable equity for google's
black plus community
and to make our products and programs
more helpful
in the moments that matter most to black
users you can learn more about these
commitments
at google.com racial
equity i'd like to close our time today
with a definition from the center for
talent innovation
according to the cti organizations can
foster a sense of belonging
particularly among underrepresented
communities by creating a culture
where all employees feel seen connected
supported and proud to be a part of
their organization
as you can see from ruby's deep dive
into women at cloud
as well as my overview of employee
resource groups at google
ergs are just one way that we work to
create a culture of belonging at google
beyond fostering a sense of community
within underrepresented groups
ergs can be a powerful tool to drive
advocacy
accountability and change across your
organization
for additional learning you can take a
look at the resources section of this
session
on our website thank you so much for
your time today